Ok so The Last Of Us is probably my favourite
game of all time.
I think it's something that transcends the
medium and that it stands toe to toe with
the best movies and tv shows.
It's easy to see why HBO have developed it
into one and throughout this video I'm gonna
be discussing why the game's ending is something
that has stuck with me since it first released
all the way back in 2013.
It's a game that I've completed multiple times
and everytime there's a remaster or remake
it's something I pick up day one just so I
can go back to it.
Though overall the gameplay is pretty straight
forward, what really elevates the Last Of
Us is it's character development and story.
Over the shoulder third person survival horror
games had become a staple of the industry
after the release of Resident Evil 4 and though
the Last Of Us doesn't really break the mould
when it comes to that, the characters go above
and beyond to elevate the entire experience.
The ending is no different and what really
pushes it is the fact that very few words
are spoken between the characters but you
can see instantly what's going on beneath
the surface.
Performance capture in video games is something
that's came a long way over the last couple
of decades and we've pretty much watched games
evolve from 2D sprites to living breathing
people who can portay their deepest thoughts
in their expressions and body language.
The Last Of Us capitalises on this massively
and Naughty Dog arguably helped to pioneer
the cinematic experience in video games.
Games have always been criticised for their
storytelling but here was a studio that put
that above all else and the game excels because
of it.
Whenever I've talked about the ending of the
Last Of Us I've always referred to it as being
The Godfather of gaming.
Now what I mean by that is that it is very
similar to the ending of another of my favourites,
The Godfather.
In that we see Michael Corleone descend to
new depths and he has his sisters husband
killed for betraying the family.
His girlfriend Kay goes to him and after Michaels
sister barges in and reveals the truth Michael
lies about it in order to not destroy the
image Kay has of him.
However from the final shot you very much
get the idea that she knows the truth but
that she's willing to accept the lie but the
reality is too horrifying to bear.
We watch the door close on her and it's somethign
that still gives me goosebumps today due to
the symbolism carried in it.
The ending of The Last Of Us is in the same
vein with Joel lying to Ellie and we see as
she very much has to force herself to believe
it because the alternative is too devastating
to accept.
We're very much left wondering if the person
we've followed throughout the entire story
is actually the good guy we were led to believe
they are and it leaves us questioning the
final few moments over and over.
We've spent hours and hours being Joel and
putting ourselves in his shoes.
We've grown a bond with the guy and seeing
him lie here is completely understandable
even if we don't totally condone it.
It really speaks to how complex the game is
as a whole and the entire thing operates in
shades of grey.
Now in order to get to this point and all
that it means we have to talk about the steps
that got us there.
This all happens because of the opening of
the game which completely defines Joels life.
In it we watch Joel and his Daugther Sarah
on the night of the Cordyseps outbreak.
After a rather laidback introductory scene,
you're thrown in at the deepend and from the
perspective of Sarah you watch the world descend
into chaos.
No one knows what is going on and in this
panic the car their in with Joels brother
Tommy is forced off the road.
Sarah's unable to properly walk and Joel has
to carry her through the streets as the infected
to start to swarm them.
They come across a lone soldier and whilst
this would normally be a sign of safety in
any other situation like this The Last Of
Us twists the scenario.
Ordered to kill the pair the soldier fires
on them and he hits Sarah.
She dies in Joels arm in a moment that will
completely rip your heart out of your chest
and it's arguably the most impactful game
opening of all time.
Now from here we get a twenty year time jump
and pick up with Joel living in a Fedra outpost.
Working as a smuggler with his girlfriend
Tess we very much get the idea throughout
the game that Joel has had to do horrendous
things to survive.
This drove a wedge between him and his brother
and it seems like he's a complete shell of
the person that he used to be.
Due to the loss that Joel faced that night
he's cut himself off emotionally so that he
doesn't have to face the emotional toil that
that took on him.
Joels entire outlook is based around surviving
and he doesn't care who he has to kill or
steal from in order to do it.
However there is still a symbol that ties
him back to his old life and that is the watch
that Sarah gave him on the night she died.
Though it's busted up and broken he still
wears it because it's the singular memory
of his daughter that remains.
The cracks in it very much represent his own
psyche and how beneath the surface he still
longs for a realtionship like the one he had
with his daughter.
Now this very much becomes the case in Ellie.
Revealed to be immune to the Cordyseps infection
she represents the hope that humanity can
find a cure and return to the old life that
everyone likely longs for.
Joel and Tess are tasked with escorting her
across the country to a firefly outpost and
we watch as Joel slowly lowers his walls in
order to let her in.
Ellie represents the daughter that he lost
and the chance to return back to a normal
life like what he had with Sarah.
There's so many subtle moments in the game
and I love the moment where Joel longingly
stares at his watch almost as if to remind
himself of that life.
There's also the fact that he called Sarah
Baby Girl which is something that he later
refers to Ellie as.
-
After Tess is killed we see Joel refusing
to talk about it or acknowledge it because
to him it's something else that he won't have
to face up to if he pushes it to the back
of his mind.
However he very clearly becomes attached to
Ellie and he even refuses to palm her off
to his brother Tommy.
Now at his outpost we get a very important
scene in which Tommy says that he returned
back to their homes in Austin Texas.
The night that the outbreak happened they
had to make a run for it and didn't get the
chance to grab any personal belongings.
Joel hasn't returned because of how painful
it is to go back there and thus it's all remained
pretty much how he left it.
Unless someones been through it and spammed
the triangle button on every square inch of
the place.
Guilty.
Anyway here Tommy found a photograph of Joel
and Sarah but he refuses to really acknowledge
it and he immediately hands it back.
However come the end of the game we learn
that Ellie grabbed this on their way out and
that she's carried it with her ever since.
She gives it to Joel and he longingly looks
at it before saying.
-
Now this is clearly a major change in him.
Rather than refusing to even acknowledge it
he puts it in his pocket and finally lets
that part of his life back in.
Now this moment is very important for both
Joel and Ellie as it's also the last major
conversation that they have before they're
quote unquote saved by the fireflies.
The pair make their way underground and after
almost drowning the pair are taken to a hospital
where they've made their camp.
Joel wakes up to discover that they're preparing
Ellie for surgery so that they can remove
the mutated strain from her which will finally
give us the hope for a cure.
There's just one thing, Ellie will die during
the procedure and in order to save humanity
they have to kill her.
Joel doesn't get the chance to say goodbye
and instead he's escorted away by an armed
guard.
At this point he pulls a fast one and kills
the soldier before brutally interrogating
him so that he can go and save her.
Now though this is completely damning humanity,
we understand Joel completely in this moment.
Like him we've become attached to Ellie throughout
the story and after spending a good ten hours
protecting her the last thing that we want
to see her do is die.
In addition to this we've seen the ugly side
of humanity throughout and obviously question
whether we're even worth saving if the cost
is going to be one of the only genuinely good
characters that we meet.
It's said that children are our future and
I think it's smart to have the game centre
around middle aged and elderly characters
because it shows how f**ked humanity is.
Sarah, Sam and Ellie are the only child characters
in the game and to have all three die could
completely kill the outlook that there's a
bright future ahead of us.
Even if players were given a dialogue tree
during this moment where we could decide what
to do I still think that the majority of people
would choose to save Ellie.
The final part of the game follows him as
we move through the hospital murdering the
Fireflies and what's probably the last brain
surgeons on the planet.
But you understand all of this because you've
been with Ellie and will do anything to stop
her from being killed.
You succeed as well and manage to make it
out of the hospital killing Marlene on the
way out.
She very much represents the opposite side
of the coin to Joel due to the backstory that
we get filled in we know that she also cared
about Ellie as well.
She was entrusted to her but Marlene is willing
to make the tough choice for the greater good.
The needs of the many outweigh the needs of
the few to her and the pair very much represent
a dichotomy over what to do.
Knowing that they won't stop coming for Ellie
he kills her in a scene and it shows just
how low he is willing to sink to protect Ellie.
It's very important to bear in mind that almost
everytime we see Marlene she's wounded and
cowering over.
This is very much the case in her final scene
and she paints out a sympathetic figure as
she lies on the ground begging for her life.
But Joel can't have Ellie with a target on
her back and thus he does what he has to in
order to make sure Ellie is safe.
Now this entire flashback is told to us with
the backdrop of Ellie waking up in the back
of a car still in her hospital gown.
Joel peddals her a story about how there's
lots of immune people out there and how the
fireflies have stopped looking for a cure.
The story doesn't even really make sense especially
due to her still being in her hospital gown.
Ellie is still too devastated to question
it though and she turns around defeated that
it's all been for nothing.
This is a moment that really stands out to
me and if we cut back to the Giraffe scene
Ellie ends up storming off because Joel offers
her a chance to return to Tommy's.
She says that it can't be for nothing and
that they have to power ahead.
Now when you think about it, the entire cure
storyline that youve spent the last how ever
many hours pushing through has been completely
pointless and you'd have been better off just
staying at Tommys in the mid point of the
game.
However that's never really crossed my mind
until this video because I've been so wrapped
up in the characters.
Even with the ending I still feel like it's
a triumphant one because you saved Ellie and
Joel finally took a step back towards humanity
rather than being the closed a cut off person
that he was.
Now they could easily end the game there and
I don't think many people would've been mad
if that had been the case.
We'd just had a major action scene, stopped
Ellie from being hunted and were riding off
into the sunset.
But The Last Of Us adds an epilogue that makes
it's ending something that will stick with
everyone long after they put the controller
down.
We don't know how big of a time jump there's
been inbetween the car ride and where we end
up but clearly some time has passed.
Juxtaposing the dynanmics that we've had throughout,
Joel is way more talkative and instead Ellie
is now the reserved one.
Eventually she stops him and brings up the
day that she got bitten and how her friend
Riley wasn't lucky enough to make it.
This is something that is later explored in
the left behind DLC and it's clear that she
suffers from survivors guilt.
Joel mirrors this as well and he says that
he struggled along time with surviving.
This is clearly commenting on how he died
instead of Sarah and he even touches the watch
for a second to signify the guilt that he
felt being someone who walked away that day
whilst Sarah didn't.
However he says that you find something to
fight for and Ellie very much represents this.
Had she died then we know that Joel would
have also have been robbed of his purpose
and that he'd be surviving with nothing to
survive for.
Now on top of this she's clearly been thinking
about the fateful day a lot and she asks Joel
flat out whether everything he said is true
or not.
-
Joel looks her dead in the eyes and swears
that it was all true.
Now I'm sure that a lot of you growing up
were told by your parents to tell them the
truth and they'd make you look them directly
in the eyes and do it to see if you were being
genuine or not.
This is normally seen as being a sign of honesty
however as humans get older we of course become
aware of this and adapt it into our lies.
It's actually said by psychologists that if
someone does this that they're more likely
to be lying because it's practiced and we
know that it's meant to convey honesty so
we purposely do it
As we know, Joel is lying here and thus him
doing this also lets us know how manipulative
he is.
All that remains is Ellie's reaction which
conveys so much.
-
I absolutely love the way this plays out and
as her eyes glance about we can read doubt,
suspicion and confusion.
She's clearly built up in her head that he's
lying but he's potentially willing to lie
on top of the lie because he doesn't want
to change the situation between them.
Ellie knows that if he's lying then he was
willing to murder people just to save her
life and she's clearly conflicted because
of this.
Now she has a couple of choices here.
Either she can say he's lying and this will
divide them further.
Or she can accept the lies and live in a world
where she won't have to deal with the survivors
guilt or truth that someone murdered people
to save her.
It's a tough thing to deal with and she simply
utters the word okay.
It's not really an acceptance or denial of
anything and instead she's just taking everything
at face value because the truth of it is far
more horrifying.
Now though I'm spouting off things that are
basically my opinion here it's completely
possible to take your own interpretation of
Ellie's thoughts at this point.
The game really wants the player to make up
their own mind and everyone will have their
own reading on this moment.
Personally I do see Ellie as being someone
that knows the truth because of the way that
Joel acts but she's willing to bury it because
she simply doesn't want to accept the reality.
Joel has been someone that has done horrendous
things in order to survive and now we see
Ellie willing to accept a lie in order to
do the same thing.
So much is given to us in this moment and
it's why the game stands the test of time.
Naughty Dog can release a remake of the game
that is completely the same as the original
because they don't need to change anything.
The story is what carries this and this final
scene that haunts players is a reason that
people keep going back to it.
It's why I think the game is something that
we're gonna be talking about for a long time
and no doubt the show will also be something
that people constantly go back to in order
to re-examine this final scene.
Though I really enjoy part 2 they could have
easily ended everything at this point and
it's why the ending is perfect.
Now I'd love to hear your thoughts on it so
I'm turning it over to you/
Comment below and let me know your thoughts
on the ending in the comments section.
We’re running a competition right now and
giving away Dawn Of The Dead and Black Adam
to 3 Subscribers on The 15th Of January.
All you have to do to be in with a chance
of winning is like the video, make sure you
subscribe with notifications on and drop a
comment below with your thoughts on the episode.
We pick the comments at random at the end
of the month and the winners of the last one
are on screen right now so message me @heavySpoilers
if that’s you.
If you want something else to watch then make
sure you check out our breakdown of perfect
scene in Spider-Man Homecoming.
We break down the entire thing so it’s definitely
worth checking out if you wanna know more.
With that out the way thank you for sitting
through the video, I’ve been Paul and I’ll
see you next time.
Take care, Peace